- Good morning believe nation.
Today's message is focus on happiness.
Over to you Zendaya.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso get me going
- Well the best thing I've
learned and advice I could give
maybe my younger self is
really to focus on happiness.
You know, happiness is
a key, because there's
so many people that you see,
that are in this industry,
or just in life in general,
that are going through
their days and may have
everything they could ever want,
but they're not happy, you know?
So you have to focus
on what makes you happy
and make decisions in
your career and your life
that make you happy.
And so I've been trying to do that
and it's working, you know.
And saying no to things that are negative.
And saying no to things you
don't want to do, you know?
So I think that's my
biggest piece of advice.
Something I try to do every
day is I try to make someone,
whether it be my team or
in my life or whatever,
just happy.
Or I try to make them feel
good or feel comfortable
or feel loved, whatever it may be.
It could be the littlest thing.
It could be just saying, oh
you look really pretty today.
Or it could be something
even smaller than that.
Or something bigger than that, you know.
It doesn't really matter
but it's just making
conscious effort to
make someone feel good.
And that could be a stranger
or it could be your mom,
you know.
- I think this is a
really important message.
I don't think entrepreneurs
focus on happiness enough.
And I think when I am most
creative, when I am in the zone
the most, when I'm working on
things that have the biggest
returns, it's when I'm happiest.
I thrive when I'm happy.
I do my best work when I'm happy.
And so I think it's
important to try to be there
as much as possible.
Now the next question,
which becomes harder,
is well, how do you stay
happy, how do you get happy
and how do you stay there.
And we've done entire videos just on that.
But I think the answer
ultimately comes down
to self-acceptance.
I think that the more
that you love yourself
and accept yourself for who you are,
and not just accepting
to be like, well that's
all I'm ever going to be,
but like love yourself.
I love these things about myself.
This thing that everybody
thinks I'm crazy about,
like he's crazy, 'cause he does that,
I love that about myself.
When you love yourself,
then what happens is
you stop doing things
because of other people.
You stop chasing something
because you want to look good
for somebody else, because you
want to just beat that person,
because you want to please somebody else.
The less you care about
other peoples' opinions
and judgments and expectations,
the less you care about
that stuff, and the more
you focus on yourself
and what makes you come alive,
and what you want to do,
and be willing to shield yourself.
It doesn't have to be in an arrogant way.
Like you don't have to put somebody down
when they have expectations of you, right?
When they think you should be doing that,
and you say, well who
are you to tell me that.
Right? You don't have to put them down.
But it also doesn't have
to impact you, you know.
I love that you guys all
have different opinions
on what I should do,
and what I should wear
and where I should go and
what my goal should be.
I love that it always, for the most part,
comes from a place of love.
It's like what you would do
if you were in my position.
But at the same time,
I'm not doing this because
you guys want me to.
I'm doing the thing I want to do,
that makes me happy.
And when you love yourself,
when you accept yourself
and love yourself, then
it makes you happier.
At least that makes me happier.
And so I'd strongly
encourage you to examine
the work that you're doing.
Why are you taking on
this project or going down
that path.
Who are you doing it for?
Are you doing it just for somebody else?
Are you doing it because
you don't want to look bad
in front of somebody else?
Are you doing it because
you're just trying
to boost your ego up or
to have a great picture
that you can post on
Facebook or Instagram?
Are you doing it because
your parents want you
to do it?
Or because you're just
trying to beat somebody else?
Or are you doing it because
you had the fire to do it.
You're doing it because you
need to express yourself
and you got to let this thing come out.
I'd strongly encourage
you to examine the reasons
why you're doing the work.
And if too many of your
projects are outward focused,
instead of I love doing
this, then you aren't really
going to be happy.
And you're not really going
to create something amazing.
So flip the switch.
Make for yourself and be happy.
So the question of the day today is
are you happy?
Are you happy with the
work that you're doing?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Luke Marcus
Jon Kroeger.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really really really
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one
word is, and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for
another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso get me going.
For those of you who want
to learn a little bit more
about how to focus on
happiness, here are some
extra bonus clips.
Hope you enjoy.
You want the flashy things,
until you know, you grow older,
you know as an adult and you'll be able
to understand yourself a little bit more.
I learned that them things
didn't make me happy.
I learned that, you know, that
really money really don't...
I'm learning that now, you
know, that's not really
my peace of mind, having money.
You know, that's something
I learned this year.
Then years before that
I learned that jewelry
and all that stuff doesn't make me happy.
And when you learn that,
you'll be able to grow
more as a person, you know.
What makes me happy is
really challenging myself
and knowing that I defeated my last goal
and took myself to the next
level as a better person.
- What's success anyway?
Is success about making the most money?
No, not, no.
Money for the most part
turns people into jerks.
If you do become rich,
the university fundraising
and development office
will certainly want to stay
in touch with you.
(laughter)
and if you give enough
money, you'll get your name
on a plaque above the
dirty laundry bin here
in the men's locker room.
But that still doesn't
make you a great person
and it definitely doesn't
mean anyone will like you.
I mean don't get me wrong,
as I mentioned before,
you're never going to feel
richer than when you've
paid off those credit
cards and student loans.
But after that, money tends
to be pretty unfulfilling.
Almost all the people I know
who've made a lot of money,
they've turned into that guy,
alright, well you know the guy
who pops his collar, and
if it were up to him,
and he were wearing two shirts,
he could pop both collars.
(laughter)
That's the guy.
So how will we know when
we've done it right.
What's the ultimate
measure of success then.
What's the key to success?
Well in my experience, quite simply,
success is happiness.
It all comes down to happiness.
And I definitely don't mean
that happiness that you feel
when the Gophers take over on
downs in their own red zone,
as great as that feels.
I mean that happiness
that quite literally fills
your lungs.
The kind of happiness that make a noise.
It announces its arrival
with a deep inhale
and a deep exhale.
(deep breath)
That happiness. You know
that happiness, right?
That happiness is success,
because it turns out,
happy people get jobs.
Happy people create. Happy people win.
Happy people fall in
love and raise families.
They lead and change the world.
Happy people get what
they want because often
happy people are the ones
who realize they don't really
need much more than they already
have, and they appreciate
what they've got.
Happy people are contagious.
- She's worried about the rent, okay.
She's a single mother.
She's worried about her kid.
- You know, there's nuttin'
you can do about the rent
from worrying about it.
That ain't going to get you no rent.
Presence and happiness gets you rent.
Money can't make you happy.
But happy can make you money.
So be happy. Go out in the world.
There's a story of a
guy in a shanty house.
He rolls over in the morning, meditates,
goes out into the world, and is like, damn
I'm going to have to
get some bread and water
'fore the whole shht go down.
Before I get back in that bed.
But in the meantime, be
nice to all my neighbors
in the shanty village.
Everybody is suffering
in what everybody else
calls extreme poverty.
But he's happy. He doesn't
have a poverty mindset.
Nor is he worried about
that bread and water.
They going to give me
some mother f'n bread,
I'm ain't going to worry about that shht.
Cause I'm that dude.
He walks out, smiling,
confident, comfortable.
He gets what he needs.
He says, but Yogananda
would say God will provide,
but really, you're god,
you're working to get
and it shows up.
He gets his bread and water.
He makes everybody happy.
Everybody makes him
happy. He lays in the bed.
The next nigga, he wakes
up, he's got 36 billion
dollars in the bank.
He gets up, the stock
market goes up, he says
oh, shht, he gets some
coke, he gets some alcohol,
he's gets happy, he's so excited.
I'm exploding. I'm making more
money, mo' money, mo' money.
Oh shht, crashed, oh shht
more cocaine, more alcohol.
Oh shht, I'm f*cked up, I'm f*cked up.
His heart goes up and down.
And he dies at 40. The shanty
house guy lived to 100.
The other guy's diet...
Not the diet the other guy
took, but the other guy's
opportunity was probably a greater diet,
the guy in the shanty house
would've made it to 120,
but you know, he made 100.
This guy died at 40.
That's the reality. Our
happiness is up to us.
Our relationship with
the world is up to us.
Our anxiety is controlled
or given to us by us.
- What Seneca is saying,
and all the Stoics,
they're not saying you can't be wealthy,
you can't be successful, you
can't go out and do things.
What they're saying is
that, you can't be dependent
on these things.
He's saying, wealth is
nice if you have it.
But if you make your
personal happiness dependent
on having this money,
that's bad, because it's not
in your control, right?
The economy can melt down at any moment.
Or your house could burn down.
Or you could lose your job.
And if you have equated wealth
with personal happiness,
now your personal happiness
is outside of your control.
And so stoicism is about
control in that sense.
How do you make the
distinction between externals
and internals and focus
most of your energy
on internals.
Having externals is nice,
but sort of what they
would say, is understand
that they're yours in trust.
Which means that they could
leave you at any moment.
And a lot of the stoic exercises are about
practicing not having those things.
So Seneca was famous he, one day a month,
he would practice being poor.
So he would wear crappy
clothes and he would not
eat at his house and
he would sleep outside.
I think it's more now a
metaphor than anything else.
But the idea is we're so
afraid of these things,
so we don't think about
them, and therefore we're not
prepared for them, and then
it makes them much scarier
and we dread them that
much more, even though
if you looked at it really objectively,
it's really not that bad.
- I had a dream to come to Barcelona,
but afterwards I'm
thinking maybe you should
keep your dream, instead
of making it come true.
Because that dream could
almost, not almost,
could have, not destroyed me,
but make it difficult for me.
And the first six months, fantastic.
I had a fantastic time.
I had a very good
relationship with Guardiola.
I wanted to learn the
Barcelona, the way of playing.
I played good the first six months.
After that, something
happened that I still don't
have answers for, which
maybe I will never know.
I mean if somebody has a problem with me,
they should come to me
and we will resolve it,
whatever the problem is, like a man.
Because it was ridiculous,
you don't talk to the player.
The player is looking for answers.
At that moment, I was not happy.
And I said, I have to choose.
Either I stay, win everything,
but I will not be happy.
Or I got to somewhere else.
And that is what happened.
I went to Milan.
My joy came back for playing football.
I did a good job. I won
the Scudetto immediately.
I won the Super Cup.
Everybody was happy and they
were like appreciating me
for playing there.